immobilien ag
eine größe
immobilien ag steine größe
guten tag frau steiner hier ist markus
fiala
[Musik]
guten tag frau steiner hier ist markus
fiala
gritz fiala wie kann ich ihnen helfen
[Musik]
wie kann ich ihnen helfen
ich interessiere mich für die drei
zimmer wohnung an der horn haldenstraße
42 in zürich
ich habe ein paar fragen
ich interessiere mich für die drei
zimmer wohnung an der horn haldenstraße
42 in zürich
ich habe ein paar fragen
ja bitte
gibt es einen parkplatz
ja aber der parkplatz ist nicht die
mietpreis inbegriffen
er kostet zusätzlich 150 franken im
monat
ja aber der parkplatz ist nicht die
mietpreis inbegriffen
er kostet zusätzlich 150 franken im
monat
entschuldigung können
bitte etwas langsamer sprechen ich
verstehe noch nicht so gut deutsch
entschuldigung können
die bitte etwas langsamer sprechen ich
verstehe noch nicht so gut deutsch
kein problem
also es gibt einen parkplatz
der kostet aber zusätzlich 120 franken
im monat
also es gibt einen parkplatz
der kostet aber zusätzlich 120 franken
im monat
das heißt die wo
nun kostet 1300 franken
plus 150 für den parkplatz
das heißt die wohnung kostet 1300
franken
plus 150 für den parkplatz
ok und in welchem stock liegt die
wohnung
im erdgeschoss
hat die wohnung auch einen keller
ja natürlich es gibt ein kellerabteil
für jede wohnung
gibt es eine wasch
schiene und einen trockner in der
wohnung
gibt es eine waschmaschine und einen
trockner in der wohnung
nein es gibt eine
nein es gibt eine waschküche
die mieter teilen sich die waschmaschine
und ein trockner
es gibt einen waschplatz
sie können immer montags und dienstags
die wäsche waschen
es gibt einen waschplatz
sie können immer montags und dienstags
die wäsche waschen
das ist gut
wann kann ich die wohnung besichtigen
die besichtigungstermine sind nächste
woche am dienstag und donnerstag von 18
bis 21 uhr
die besichtigungstermine sind nächste
woche am dienstag und donnerstag von 18
bis 21 uhr
der aktuelle meter heißt ulf schäfer sie
müssen bei ihm klingeln
entschuldigung können sie das bitte
wiederholen dass das war zu schnell
entschuldigung
wenn sie das bitte wiederholen dass das
war zu schnell
die termine sind nächste woche am
dienstag und donnerstag von 18 bis 21
uhr
die termine sind nächste woche am
dienstag und donnerstag von 18 bis 21
uhr
sie müssen bei herrn schäfer klingeln
gut vielen dank
[Musik]
bitteschön auf wiederhören herr fiala
auf wiederhören frau steiner
guten morgen guten tag
wohnen sie hier
ja ich heiße angela salvatore
ich wohne mit meinen freundinnen dritten
stock
a
freut mich
ich heiße erwin ziegler
da freut mich
ich heiße levin ziegler
ich und meine familie wohnen im
erdgeschoss
woher kommen sie
ich komme aus italien
wie lange leben sie schon in der schweiz
wie lange
geben sie schon in der schweiz
vier monate
sie sprechen gut deutsch
vielen dank
ich gehe ihn
deutschkurs
vielen dank
ich gehe in ein
deutschkurs
a
ich muss jetzt gehen ich muss zur arbeit
schön
es hat mich gefreut sie kennenzulernen
auf wiedersehen frau salvatore
danke gleichfalls
einen schönen tag herr ziegler
hallo deutsche schule deutsch lernen mit
spaß
hat dir das video gefallen abonniere
unseren kanal hat dir das video gefallen
abonniere unseren kanal